So remember when, like Russia was meddling in
the American election and everyone was really
afraid and it was this terrible thing? Turns
out that this is something that the U.S. has
done forever. Like one of the things that the U.S.
has done a ton over the course of its history is
throw out leaders in other countries that it
doesn't like or meddle in their elections or
in their politics. That's what a coup is. And the
U.S. got really into this, especially during the
Cold War. They would send the CIA in to like
go foment protests and stuff and eventually
oust the leader. Sometimes they would
like actually just like full on,
like assassinate the leader. It happened all over
the world, in fact I’ve been, like, deep in this,
trying to map all of the different coups, way too
many for me to cover. So I just settled on like
17 of them that were particularly fascinating and
horrific. And I think after spending a lot of time
thinking about coups, it was just a reminder
for me that we think we live in this world of
like order and like there's rules and treaties
and all this stuff. But at the end of the day,
countries with the most power, they're
going to get their way no matter what.